le 21e siècle vous appartient et ne
laissez personne vous le volet ne
laissez personne vous priver de votre
avenir
il est temps un moment ou un autre de
faire entendre votre voix et qu'elle
passe au dessus du bruit de fond notre
société qu'elle s'impose à chacun et
qu'elle demande impérativement aux uns
et aux autres aux politiques en
particulier mais pas seulement un moment
ou un autre de parler moi mais d'agir
demandez-leur d'ouvrir grand les yeux
d'être lucide
dites leur de faire les choses en grand
de changer d'échelle de ton change et
d'ambition d'arrêter de se confronter
pour des broutilles de se retrouver sur
l'essentiel d'y aller à fond sur la
transition énergétique sur la transition
du modèle alimentaire de ne pas
s'entêter dans un modèle économique
dominant qui n'est plus la solution mais
qui est bien le problème
faites-le quelle que soit la forme sans
jamais céder ni à la violence ni à la
bêtise la violence c'est de la défaite
de la pensée
opposée à la violence les idées la
créativité l'inventivité fait chanter
les mots ce qui manque cruellement à
notre société
solidarité qui doit être dorénavant
l'adn de notre société
sobriété parce qu'on peut faire beaucoup
mieux avec beaucoup moins diversité
parce que seule la diversité et féconde
humilité arrêtons de nous prendre pour
des dieux et redonner du sens au progrès
il ya tout sur la table mais choisis
sont dans les priorités ayons une vision
réconcilions-nous avec la nature et puis
surtout prenons un peu le temps de la
conscience ne faisons pas simplement les
choses parce qu'on sait les fermes parce
qu'elle participe à l'épanouissement
humain
c'est tous ces messages que vous devez
tenter de faire passer prioritairement
samedi à la marche du siècle mais vous
arrêtez pas là dorénavant il faut jamais
que votre voix soit couverte par
l'indifférence ou la vanité
exprimez vous exprimez vous sur toutes
les formes
je ne doute pas que vous ne manquerez
pas d'imagination
on a besoin de vous pour vous mettre
nous les adultes ça ça nous
responsabilité